what do you want more of by scepter
Rolex hey guys I'm Tom Segura 9 / are
burnt crystals they brought back the two
biggest guests from hot ones to do one
episode together that's right it's not
Kevin Horton Shaquille O'Neal it's
[ __ ] wale when I was 23 I got
involved with awesome I'll say god
dammit hey guys check this out a truther
dab this week hot ones first we feast
first we feast
Bert Tom let's go
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and welcome back
to another episode of truth or dab the
hot ones special where we give our
guests two simple options tell the truth
or suffer the wrath of the last app and
today we're joined by two of our
favorite comedians friends of the brand
Tom Segura and Bert Kreischer they both
have Netflix specials out right now your
mom's house of burped cast wherever you
get your podcasts and catch tom live on
the second half of his take it down tour
tickets on sale now and coming to a city
near you and for Bert fans fall tour
dates for his body shots world tour will
be announced later this month get your
tickets Bert Tom welcome to the show
thanks buddy thank you for having both
of us in front of you you guys have
three scorching hot chicken wings that
have all been doused in various versions
of the last dab of a series of personal
potentially awkward questions for each
of you you realized how hard that's
gonna be to live my career our careers
made on just saying the worst things
about ourselves on our podcast for the
last nine years I'm dying to see these
questions well we'll see how far we can
push you guys today and Bert let's start
with you you seem eager I'm very eager
you just finished the North American leg
of your body shots tour of the 28 cities
you've visited which one was the biggest
dump can't wait to come back next year
[Laughter]
started diving right in ruggle it was
Albany how's that there's no bad man
really unclear this boat I can see there
is going in mondaya committee well on
the tour is hot yeah
hmm Burt you don't like you forgot what
it's like to be here you know you just
have me a bottle of this on my tour bus
I gave it to my assistant Cobra and he
threw up immediately started throwing up
it's a good sales point yeah yeah it's
not this part it's when it comes out
that's a bad one
yeah after I did hot ones the first time
season two how was it early plan you
were for his famous family yeah I know
and I tell everyone that holy [ __ ] what
was he talking about I [ __ ] my pants and
security going through the airport LAX
you don't forgot the beginning part of
the story I will last time I was on hot
ones I did [ __ ] my pair a bucket all
right what's next question these tables
go lower
oh is this for Kevin Hart when you think
it might be weight related Tom it's your
turn okay in your intro you host your
mom's house podcast along with your wife
and co-host Cristina Pia fellow comedian
what's the secret that you've kept from
her that she would not be happy to hear
if she were say watching right now
in a winger oh oh tom diving in bert
setting a high bar so tom now tell it no
telling
ohso bad hey Pat Oh ma'am
dude this is like taking a vicodin your
brain just shuts down I jerked off on
our pillow we do supposed to eat the
wings and then tell the truth
yeah choice you know if you're gonna
tell the truth you don't have to eat the
wing that was really bad
oh it hurts the laugh are these hot or
do they gonna get hotter round two all
right you guys roll with a group of
heavy hitters and comedy but it's time
to burn some bridges Bert ranked these
comedians from funniest to least funny
human Joey Diaz
Ari Shaffir Joe Rogan and Tom Segura
[Music]
yeah okay
holy [ __ ] man yeah
how is this so much worse than last time
you get to kind of work your way up to
the last step when you're on the show
here very steep ramp up when we just lay
three less to have wings down or use the
loose funny let me say that okay you
don't actually have to answer I just
wanted to put that out there so everyone
knew that
or is it loose all right Tom yeah again
stir in the pot a little bit I know that
you're a very nice guy but comedy it's a
competition
it's a sport so keep it 100 who has the
worst stand-up special on Netflix right
now who I know it I know you know until
we just talked about it in the green
room yeah [ __ ] I can't talk goddamn it
dude what are you doing
it's a tough show it's a tough show yeah
you have a least favorite one
disgraceful
[Laughter]
goddamnit throw an adapter what I really
wanted after that one I don't know the
answer well now there's no point well
something a little something
yeah okay what you have said was it
wasn't meant to be funny and it was like
it was I thought provoker was a TED talk
who's good can we see her next one all
right on to Round three might have to
toss some more wings for these guys my
mouth is on [ __ ] fire bro
Tom yeah you're known as the water champ
right here we're gonna actually put that
Aquaman knowledge to the test I know
it's one thing to drink water and call
yourself the water champ but how much do
you really know about water I'm gonna
hit you with a water pop quiz get all
three of these questions right you're
totally in the clear but get one wrong
you know the drill [ __ ] win all right or
how much of the human body is water and
I mean a normal body not like a water
champs body is it twenty percent sixty
percent or 95 percent sexy is it know
how it's gonna be 60 you fill with blood
your skin's ten no it's sexy
sixty percent six percent good job tom
all right which of the Great Lakes is
the deepest between Lake Superior Lake
Michigan and Lake Ontario tear coming
down it's always that left Tom Michigan
right it is superior
god damn let's
let's do this oh you're crying yeah we
are in let's do a little double or
nothing all right okay you have that
wing let's go to this last question here
all right you get it right you're in the
clear but get it wrong will up the
stakes you'll dab last wing okay okay
well you saying right you gotta pour
some stuff hold it I heard him he sold
in a 14-carat diamond-encrusted bottle
Beverly Hills 9o h2o claims to sell the
most expensive bottle of water in the
world how much does it cost forty five
thousand dollars seventy five thousand
dollars were a hundred grand come on man
what the [ __ ] is happening here the most
expensive bottle of water under in the
world it is $100,000 what did you do it
is $100,000 Tom Segura with the lifeline
swerves that pothole I got you my man I
got you man we still got two rounds to
go dude
it went away and then I wiped my mouth
with my thing and it came back again
Bert you guys are both prolific
podcasters in the over 300 episode
history of the Burke cast who has been
your worst guest
Oh had the answer
[Music]
I got two answers should we go with the
one that everyone hated the most no I
can't put I can't pull it on glass like
that there's one you know more that girl
bit yeah yeah she's Irish what's the
other one I don't know some guy he was
he's like I'm not gonna put anyone on
blast but you you're already he already
kind of did what I didn't okay okay good
you did name it you did out it we could
do the math all right Tom yeah joke
stealing it's one of the biggest taboos
and comedy can you out a comedian who
you believe has gotten away with ripping
material from other committees truther
dab or ruining your career it's not even
about like not saying it I can't [ __ ]
think of one right now whisper in my ear
I'll say it I'll say after you say oh
[Laughter]
just turn the levels up on what he said
does that count
alright I'm just one more wig to go you
could just eat it and it's all Albert
he's everybody's jokes is there it
worked
that's where I got the machine story
oops hey jumpy big joke deep well listen
there's no robbing your way out of this
one okay
it is now pop quiz time for you you're a
product of Tampa a Florida State grad a
Sunshine State dirtbag and proud of it
if I've ever seen one so what I'm gonna
do is give you a handful a series of
Florida man have
and it's up to you to figure out if they
are real or if they're fake Florida man
denies syringes found in his rectum are
his real or fake that's I I can see I
bet that's real it is real it is you
totally see myself in the back of a car
one I don't know how they got there it's
true as reported by news channel local
10 that's 40 year old Wesley Scott's
story and he's sticking to it to more
headlines to go Bert you guys just easy
peasy Florida man
flashes his buttocks at IHOP after
impersonating a police officer to get
free food real or fake
it's the end part that's throwing me
about after impersonate because the
first part you're like oh that died
happens once a week I'm gonna go real it
is real it is real
according to the Orlando Sentinel when
asked if he had money 55 year old Matt's
Gitta said no but I am a cop and get
food for free obviously things spiraled
a little bit after that so big Florida
moves it's gonna be a collar to move all
right Bert one more headline for you
yeah you know the drill get it right
here in the clear get it wrong that wing
is waiting for you my mouth feels
perfect right now okay huh [ __ ] him okay
Florida man sent to jail after pouring
hot sauce on three month old puppy
that's fake that is unfortunately real
[ __ ] fortunately gizmo is set to make a
full recovery but that is a real
headline they were real
very cocky put a lot of last dab lose it
is it uh by the way this is a real fan
right here is it a Coolio tab that's a
real fan right that's a real fan right
there what happened to Coolio
it did have bad you know it was really
bad I sued them I worked with Coolio
once Oh your dad's a dick
Wow Bert cleaning wings getting through
five rounds that feel like now it hurts
my molars
I feel sick yeah some unique chemistry
going on
down hmm
one more question to go to her questions
I know more wing Bert you're done you're
done you can cuddle it one more wait how
did you make that but you know what Bert
you're not off the hot seat because this
one comes right at you Tom
which of Bert's bits do you pretend to
laugh at because you're a good and
supportive friend but deep down you
think is hacky and once you get a friend
to tell them I leave the link don't
answer not try to think y'all do
something for you real quick
yeah well my kids are dumb as [ __ ] my
daughter doesn't run me through some
other businessman my wife farted during
oral sex
fire in the hole how's it going I like
to spread them out when in doubt spread
them out that's a good one yeah doing um
pajamas my dad yeah that's relate but I
was like you know you know hmm
see uh I can tell you my answer hey no
he didn't she's spirt leading the
witness
I mean I'm over the machine story
he has had it with the machine story one
of the greatest hits
it's a greatest hit keep an eye out body
shots world tour
it doesn't stop doing an international
run and then the fall dates Tom Segura
take it down tickets on sale now visit
Tom Segura calm Bert Bert Bert calm Tom
Segura calm Bert Bert Bert calm great
domain name to get a hold of the four
birch was already taken that's it for
truth our dad
I felt that oh my god I almost threw up
on that last one hey you know what I'm
soaking wet when you tour
internationally it's probably really
good for your health
yeah hey what's going on hot ones fans I
hope that you enjoyed today's episode of
truth there Deb I don't ask for much
around here but you can see the pin
comment below we've been nominated for a
Webby it would mean a lot to the crew
here if you could vote us on to win I
know that it would mean the world to Tom
and Sarah Honda Chris and perhaps most
of all camera guy bill if you could
throw us to subscribe and again don't do
it for me do it for bill